YEN-JIE LEE: So
during the semester,
we have a few
recitation instructors.
They help with the students
during the recitation section.
So during those sections,
usually the instructor
will solve a similar problem,
like what is actually
covered during the lecture.
And that gives the
students another chance
to look at more example
and to get familiar or get
used to the calculation which we
carried out for the first time
during the lecture.
So also the recitation section--
during the recitation
section, the instructors
help the students.
So they can actually ask more
questions during the recitation
sections, including
the questions
they have in the p-set or
any additional questions
they thought about
after the lecture.
OK.
So that they get
another chance to clear
some of the concepts
which they don't really
understand during the lecture.
So we did not record
the recitation sections
during the Fall
semester in 2016.
On the other hand, we included
problem-solving videos
from Professor Wit
Busza, which is
similar to what we do during
the recitation sections
from previous years, to go
with the lecture videos done
during the semester.